Erinnert ihr euch noch an CVC, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Ja, das waren die, die damals bei der Bundesliga einsteigen wollten. Turns out, jetzt haben sie Refinanzierungsprobleme und mussten sich selber Investoren reinholen für ihr Sportgeschäft. Was heißt das und was geht überhaupt so im Bereich der Investoren im Fußball? Darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit Christoph Neßhöfer vom Manager Magazin und Jannik Tillar von Kapital und Stern. Und los geht's.
Das muss man jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen, damit ist das Projekt beendet.
Für mich, das sage ich ganz klar, ist das eine Niederlage der Zentralfamilie.
Dabei sollte uns bitte die nächste Zeit niemand mehr irgendwie mit Solidaritätsthemen kommen, denn solidarischer, wie wir uns hier aufgestellt hatten, gerade die großen Klubs, solidarischer kann man nicht mehr sein.
Dann im Nachgang beleidigte Leberwürste, sich in der Pressekonferenz dann auch hinzusetzen, also ganz ehrlich, das ist auch nicht in Ordnung, wenn man einer solchen großen Verantwortung gerecht werden will. Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Die Arbeit dafür hat 40.000 Mitarbeiter und nicht irgendwie so wie Bayern.
Ja gut, aber die kennen sie ja nicht alle. Die Verantwortung, die Verkennungszwecklichkeiten.
Also vielleicht, also ehrlicherweise, ich glaube dir alles, was du sagst, aber das ist ja eine groteske Überschätzung des Fußballs und auch von Einzelpersonen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so grotesk ist, ich darf es doch nicht vergessen. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, nur weil Adidas 60.000 Mitarbeiter hat, bei einem mittelgroßen Bundesliga-Klub, du arbeitest ja de facto auch für alle Mitglieder oder Fans. Du hast natürlich eine Stakeholder-Gruppe, die ist noch viel größer als bei Adidas.
Also wenn Adidas jetzt nicht gerade ein neues Trikot vorstellt, ist das ja weitaus weniger politisch als ein Fußballverein, sage ich mal.
Oh, da könnt ihr euch auf das erste Nike-Trikot vom DFB freuen, da habe ich ganz fürchterliche Geschichten. Ich habe nur Geschichten gehört bisher, aber der DFB ist schockiert. Aber gut, das ist jetzt mal ein komplett anderes Thema.
Die werden noch ganz anders schockiert werden von Nike, aber das wird man dann sehen.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gehört. Aber um das noch kurz zu sagen, ich werde natürlich diesen UEFA-Report verlinken. Ich habe ihn auch gelesen. Deutschland ist tatsächlich auf Platz zwei bei der Steigerung, wie viel mehr Geld eben in diese Nicht-Spieler-Gehälter reinging. Also auf Platz eins ist es die Premier League und dann kommt tatsächlich schon Deutschland. Aber Jannik, du wolltest auch schon etwas sagen.
Nö, also eigentlich nur fast noch ergänzend an Christoph. Also man muss, also zu dem Punkt, dass die keinen Gewinn erzählen, könnte halt auch dieses Thema Wachstum einfach noch mal entzukommen. Also es ist wie bei Wachstumsunternehmen bei, keine Ahnung, bei Magnificent Seven an der Börse, also so Google und wie sie alle heißen. Die machen jetzt zwar viel Gewinn, aber, oder nennen wir das mal jüngere Unternehmen, die müssen nicht unbedingt Gewinn erzielen, solange die Wachstumsgeschichte aufwärts geht. Also du musst ständig eine neue Geschichte erfinden, um den Leuten, wie Christoph sagt, diese Greater Fool Theorie, also du musst das immer in den Next Dimmeren verkaufen können. Und das, ja, solange sich narrativ diese Geschichte aufrechtgehalten wird, solange man vom Wachstum erzählen kann, solange die Leute das jedenfalls abkaufen, solange es Gewinn erstmal, glaube ich, zweitrangig.
Ja, okay, also das ist ja quasi das Bitcoin-Prinzip. Solange es immer noch neue Leute reingeht, die reingehen, dann ist es egal, dass eigentlich alle Bitcoins drei Leuten gehören.
Und jetzt sind wir endgültig auf dem Index bei YouTube.
Ja, ja, und ich freue mich auch auf die E-Mails, aber es ist mir egal, Leute, ich habe recht, werden wir schon in ein paar Jahren dann noch sehen. Aber das, okay, das verstehe ich ja, aber gleichzeitig bewegen wir uns ja jetzt hier nicht in einem abgeschlossenen Zirkel, in dem halt die Sportbewertungen wachsen. Also mir ist es zum Beispiel aufgefallen, bei der Major League Soccer sind logischerweise auch, da sind insgesamt 17 Teams in Multiclub-Ownership-Strukturen drin. Wundert einen ja auch nicht wirklich. Und da ist die Bewertung der Teams extrem hoch und die ist auch extrem gestiegen. Aber man muss dazusagen, diese Bewertung, die wird so ein bisschen aus der Luft gegriffen. Also klar, liegen da ökonomische Zahlen drunter, aber letztlich sind es dann Branchenportale oder irgendwelche Analysten, die da einfach mal so eine Zahl hinschreiben und dann sagen die ja, Inter Miami ist jetzt x-wert und Vancouver Whitecaps ist y-wert und so weiter. Und ob das aber wirklich mal so ist, das liegt eben dann daran, ob man den Greater Fool findet. Aber wir befinden uns ja auch innerhalb einer Weltwirtschaft und wir wissen ja, gerade so Private Equity Geld ist dann schon eines, was sehr fluide ist. Denn es fließt dahin, wo die Rendite noch möglich ist. Und gleichzeitig sehen wir, im Sport sind wenige Investoren jetzt sehr breit investiert. Und du kommst eigentlich auch als kleiner Investor gar nicht mehr rein. Das sagen Analysten, die sich das ganze Feld des Sport-Investments angucken, sagen das selbst inzwischen. Kann das nicht auch heißen, Jannik, wenn einer fällt, dann fallen alle? Also lass zum Beispiel am einen Ende des Spielfelds die KI-Bubble platzen und dann trickelt das rüber und dann ist es aber ganz schnell so, dass im Sport gar nicht mehr hochbewertet wird. Und dann, ja, was passiert denn dann eigentlich?
Ja, also das kann auf jeden Fall passieren. Das hat dann aber, also wenn es so weit kommt, dann hat nicht nur ein Sport ein Problem, also das ist ganz unabhängig. Das ist definitiv ein Thema, was aber immer wieder auch diskutiert wird. Das haben wir aktuell zum Beispiel auch bei der Debatte um Zinsen, um höhere Zinsen, die sich jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt gerade aus dem Iran-Krieg da ergeben könnten, wenn die Ölpreise weiter hoch bleiben, dass die Zinsen dann steigen müssten. Und gerade das würde halt PIV massive Probleme führen, weil das Druck auf die Bewertung macht. Und das würde dann halt auch entsprechend auf die Bewertung im Sport drücken im nächsten Schritt. Das passiert jetzt dann alles nicht von heute auf morgen, aber das sind Entwicklungen, die dann irgendwie real werden. Und dann wird man sich ganz genau fragen. Also es ist immer die Dynamik. Es wird erst mal geguckt, was wirklich werthaltig ist und was nicht werthaltig ist. Und das war zum Beispiel 2022 bei dem letzten Zinszyklus, als der Zins nach oben gegangen ist, war es ja auch so, dass Tech-Werte oder unprofitable Werte als erstes abgestraft werden. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass, wenn das so kommt, also es ist ja alles noch so ein bisschen gerade in der Schwebe, aber wenn tatsächlich die Zinsen steigen sollten und das im Iran auch nicht weitergeht, dann könnte es dazu führen, dass auch der Sport dann in näherer Zukunft da vor Probleme gestellt wird, weil eben gesagt wird, ja, das ist jetzt nicht so werthaltig, wie wir uns das gedacht haben. Wir gehen mal lieber in sicherere Anlageklassen. Das wäre eine Folge davon beispielsweise.
Aber es könnte auch umgekehrt sein. Weil diese These, dass der Sport verhältnismäßig unabhängig ist von der Gesamtwirtschaftsentwicklung, die ist schon immer noch stark. Die sehe ich schon immer noch oft und da spricht ja auch einiges dafür. Zum Beispiel das Argument, dass nach Corona eigentlich die alten Level wieder erreicht worden sind oder sogar übertroffen worden sind. Das war ja zwischendurch absolut nicht klar. Es gab die Angst der Bundesligan, nach Corona bleiben die Stadien zu 28 Prozent leer, weil da keiner mehr hingeht und weil sich alle abgewöhnt haben, dahin zu gehen. Das ist in der Form nicht eingetroffen. Da gab es ja interne Szenarien, die waren echt finster. Ist aber nicht eingetroffen. Das heißt, du kannst genauso argumentieren, dass die dann sagen, na okay, da und dort und hier geht es gegen die Werte runter, aber da ist immer noch eine Stabilität drin und dann gehe ich da eher noch rein. Und vielleicht noch ein Satz zu den Bewertungen. Also meine Erfahrung oder meine Meinung ist, jede Unternehmensbewertung ist immer nur vor allem Interessen gesteuert und die wird in dem Moment erst zu einer echten Bewertung, wenn es einen Verkaufsprozess gibt. Also wenn da jemand gegenüber sitzt und der sagt, ich zahle X und der Bündnisneuer sagt, ich will aber Y. So und dann wird eine Bewertung gemacht und dann am Ende einigen die sich irgendwo und dann hast du eine Bewertung, die dann für einen Tag sozusagen gilt. Ja und am nächsten Tag schon wieder andere. Alles andere, was da immer gemacht wird, ist, also ich weiß das ein kleines bisschen, weil wir machen ja jedes Jahr das Nebenthema die Liste der reichsten Deutschen und ich bewerte da jedes Jahr die ganzen großen Familienunternehmen und so weiter. Nicht wie ein Wirtschaftsprüfer, halt wie ein Journalist, aber ich sehe das eigentlich immer, dass die diese Bewertung, da gibt es extremste Schwankungen, je nachdem, welches Modell du anwendest, welche Kernzahlen du nutzt, das sind extreme Unterschiede. Deswegen bin ich immer extrem vorsichtig bei diesem, wir bewerten die Unternehmenssohn, so bewertet. Im Sport würde ich eher sagen, im Fußball würde ich sagen, naja, in dem Moment, wenn so ein Klub absteigt, geht die Wert natürlich runter, klar, weil die Erlöse sinken. Na nur, wie viel das der Fall ist, das ist, finde ich, extrem schwer zu sagen. Das weißt du erst, wenn dann jemand kommt und sagt, ich kaufe den jetzt für einen Abschlag von 50 Prozent oder so, und der kriegt das dann auch, den Deal. Dann kannst du sagen, ja, das ist der Wert. Deswegen finde ich das immer so ein bisschen, da ist schon viel so Finger in den Wind halten und mal gucken, wo es so rauskommt, was uns gerade in unseren Interessen passt. Natürlich werden die Besitzer immer sagen, ist viel mehr wert und die Käufer werden immer sagen, ist viel weniger wert. Völlig klar. Und die Börse hat nochmal eine ganz andere Meinung, wobei ja nicht so viele Clubs jetzt börsennotiert sind. Manche Investoren natürlich klar. Da wäre ich also ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Die Multiples, es wird da quasi immer auf eine Bewertungsgrundlage, beispielsweise den Umsatz oder den Gewinn, wird ein Multiplikator drauf gesetzt und gesagt, das ist ungefähr so viel wert. Sagen wir mal zehnmal Gewinn oder so bei einem Wachstumsunternehmen. Das ist aber auch ein bisschen willkürlich. Und ich glaube, das wird auch dann in Zukunft nicht anders sein.
Ja, aber trotzdem habe ich jetzt immer noch nicht so ganz verstanden, warum so viele Investoren in Vereine oder in Clubs dann eben reingehen. Also das eine ist natürlich Synergieeffekte. Okay, das speichere ich ab. Ich würde allerdings auch sagen, so richtig geklappt hat das noch nirgendwo. Nicht mal Chelsea mit ihren drei Mannschaftsbussen großen Kader hätten sie jetzt hinbekommen. Also könnt euch mal angucken, was der aktuelle Trainer, der von Straßburg kam, da bei Chelsea gerade so macht. Da wird dabei gerade angebetet. Und naja, also ob das so gut geht, da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher. Also das ist natürlich das eine. Man kann mögliche Synergieeffekte sehen. Und das andere, das müssen wir völlig ausklammern, ist quasi alles non-monetäre. Also ich will eben Werbung machen für meinen Start oder mein Produkt. Das ist ja klar. Aber alle anderen gehen dann quasi rein und hoffen, dass sie den Greater Fool finden. Also dass sie irgendwann wieder rausgehen können für einen Gewinn. Aber gleichzeitig sind ja irgendwann alle drin und es können ja auch nicht alle gewinnen. Also wir haben den Sonderfall US-Sport noch, da ist auch viel Bewegung reingekommen. Die NFL hat als erste Liga eine 10% Beteiligung für Investoren zugelassen. Dann ging es richtig ab und inzwischen ist der US-Sport aufgeteilt. Aber ehrlicherweise ist der US-Sport auch aufgeteilt zwischen irgendwie 5 bis 8 Playern, wenn man das mal so rausrechnet. Und die sind jetzt halt einfach überall mit so 5, 10% drin und so weiter. Und das ist dann eher, glaube ich, infrastrukturell, weil da kannst du nicht rausverkaufen. Aber wenn wir beim Fußball bleiben, irgendwann wirst du kein greater Fool mehr finden. Und dann verstehe ich das nicht, weil die haben ja auch alle einen Zinsdruck. Also das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, aber man kennt halt nicht so viele Zahlen. Aber die City Football Group, die zahlt pro Jahr 73 Millionen Pfund an Zinsen, weil sie eben Fremdkapital reinholen mussten. Und diesen Druck, den haben doch andere Investoren auch. Wir haben ja gerade bei CVC gelernt, die mussten sie auch Fremdkapital reinholen, auch wenn es jetzt ein anderes Thema ist. Aber erklärt es mir, ich verstehe es immer noch nicht.
Soll ich Christoph kurz anfangen?
Ich habe noch einen anderen Punkt, der ist ein bisschen abseitiger.
Fangen du mal an. Ich glaube, die Gründe, die changieren auch mal so ein bisschen. Also es war vielleicht mal zu einer gewissen Zeit stärker diese Wachstumserzählung. Und ich glaube, jetzt geht es ein bisschen mehr in diese Richtung von, was wir jetzt gerade auch schon gesagt haben, Krediten und sicheren Erträgen oder Credits. Also letztlich geht es ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung, wir wollen stabile Zahlungsrückflüsse haben und sehen das so als eine Art Kreditgeschäft, so Infrastruktur nochmal. Also Sport wächst nicht mehr so stark, aber es hat ja immer noch relativ solide, man hat erwartbare Cashflows aus Medien, man kann ungefähr wissen, wie viele Leute ins Stadion gehen. Es ist ein relativ unabhängig vom Gesamtmarkt sich entwickelndes Geschäft. Das heißt, man hat einigermaßen verlässliche Zahlungsströme und das ist halt auch ein Asset, eine Stärke vom Sport.
Das ist quasi das neue Sparbuch, aber funktioniert eben nur so lange, wie der Rückfluss aus den Vereinen größer ist als der Zins oder eben der MCSI World Index.
Ja, genau. Wobei, es ist ja so ein bisschen abgekoppelt davon, dass die Medienrechte nicht unbedingt direkt was mit den Vereinsgewinnen zu tun. Deswegen, ich glaube, das kann man schon unabhängig voneinander betrachten. Und ich glaube einfach, dass das gerade das Narrativ ist, was auch in Zukunft erstmal noch gespielt wird. Also wir werden noch mehr erleben, dass sich einzelne Ligen, einzelne Vereine mehr auf Kredite reinholen und viel mehr schuldenfinanziert arbeiten, als jetzt noch neue Investoren an Bord holen und sich da irgendwie Eigenkapitalfinanzierung machen, oder also neue Private Acquities oder so da reinholen. Ich glaube einfach dort, dass die Nachfrage auch höher ist und so ein bisschen die Fantasie raus ist. Aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
Christoph?
Ich wollte noch einen Punkt reinschmeißen, der glaube ich selbst für noch so abgezockte Investoren ein Stück weit gilt. Das ist Emotion. Ich habe vor zehn Jahren mal eine Geschichte gemacht über Investoren im Fußball und hatte unter anderem telefoniert und weil ich damals zitiert habe, kann ich das erzählen, mit Uts Klassen. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das was sagt. Uts Klassen war ein deutscher Top-Manager, der war mal CEO von NBW, also einem Energieversorger. Er hat dann noch einiges andere versucht. Er war, glaube ich, schon immer mal bei VW. Ein ziemlich schillernder Typ. Der war dann irgendwann raus. Er hat natürlich klotzig verdient und hat sich in Mallorca angesiedelt oder hatte da eh schon irgendwie Eigentum. Als ich den damals sprach, war der gerade Investor bei RCD Mallorca. Der hat sich da eingekauft, nicht wenig. Ich glaube, der hatte einen zweistelligen Prozentsatzanteil da an dem Club und hat dann auch teilweise im Aufsichtsrat gesessen und glaube ich dann später auch mal die Geschäftsführung geführt. Und dann habe ich mit ihm darüber gesprochen, über sein Investment. Und dann hat er einen Satz gesagt und den titiere ich jetzt mal, warum er das eigentlich gemacht hat. Und dann hätte er natürlich sagen können, weil ihm langweilig war auf Mallorca. Das hat er natürlich nicht gesagt, aber er hat einen Satz gesagt, den fand ich gut. Er hat gesagt, naja, die finanzielle Rendite verspreche ich mir ja gar nicht groß, aber die emotionale Rendite, die ist priceless. Also die kann mir nichts ersetzen. Also die Tatsache, sich da hinzusetzen, in diesem Stadion, bei den Spielen dabei zu sein, mitzuschiebern und gleichzeitig zu wissen, na du bist irgendwie, du bist ein Investor, du bist daran beteiligt. Und ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, ich weiß das auch von Leuten, die in der Normalwirtschaft unterwegs sind, die da irgendwie im Fußball sind, die sagen, das ist einfach auch ein Teil der Geschichte. Selbst solche abgezockten Investoren. Fußball ist so emotional und zieht die Leute so dermaßen an, dass das für solche Leute echt ein Mehrwert an sich schon ist. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, warum ist Abramovic da eingestiegen? Klar, aus Reputationsgründen natürlich, aber der findet das auch geil, da zu sitzen. Ja, allein das, der hat jedes Mal, wenn er da sitzt im Stadion und er wird dann noch gefilmt und er ist der Owner und so weiter, dann ist das die emotionale Rendite. Und die ist enorm hoch, je nachdem, wie die Leute so gestrickt sind. Und das gilt selbst für Leute, die Geld geben an irgendein anderen, also irgendein Investitionsvehikel, wie die auch alle heißen und sich dann, wenn sie zu Hause im Fußball sitzen und Fußball gucken und sie zu Hause im Fußball gucken, sich dann sagen können, ja, ich bin daran beteiligt über den Fond von Schlag mich tot. Ich bin da mit Eigentümer, da macht es noch viel mehr Spaß. Ich glaube, dass das auch, damit geht der Fußball ja auch hausieren, damit gehen die auch an die Leute ran, als Verkaufsargument, als Einstiegsargument. Sie sagen, wenn du bei uns einsteigst, dann bist du ganz tief drin und du gehörst dazu und du bist Teil der Fußball-Community und du kannst dich noch viel mehr über die Erfolge freuen oder über Niederlagen auch ärgern, als du das kannst, wenn du einfach nur Sport-Wetten-Auf-XC-Zuschauern bist.
Da wird einem auch suggeriert, wenn du noch eine Wette abschließt.
Und jetzt wollte ich nochmal sagen, und dieses Segment Sport ist für die Großinvestoren klein. Und natürlich haben die in ihren Portfolien Bereiche, wo die Geld reinstecken, das ist dann sozusagen das Spielgeld für die, wo die sagen, das kann grandios funktionieren. Und da bist du beim Thema wetten. Es kann aber auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es grandios funktioniert, nicht so hoch. Aber für mich ist die hoch genug, um das Risiko einzugehen. Und wenn es dann weg ist, ist es weg. Und das spielt auch eine Rolle. Weil der Fußball schon auch, das wissen auch Profi-Investoren, ein Stück weit irrational ist. Ich meine, zum Beispiel der ein Argument bei dem Beitrag von den Kollegen über RB Leipzig bei dem Internet. Freunde waren näher, die hatten halt früher, haben sie halt Spieler raus dem Netzwerk geholt wie Harland, Sorbus Lai und Leimer. Und sei es dann nicht mehr gekommen seit langem. Ja, stimmt, wahrscheinlich, ich kann nicht so beurteilen, aber wahrscheinlich hast du solche Kaliber nicht mehr gehabt. Aber das ist natürlich auch, behaupte ich jetzt mal, auch immer ein bisschen Glückssache. Guck dir an, wie die Vereine grugeln um irgendwelche Jungspieler. Und dann geht es in die Hose. Guck dir meinen Lieblingsverein, erster FC Köln, jetzt haben wir den Elmaler, den vor eineinhalb Jahren keiner haben wollte. Da waren er noch jünger, aber haben sie den in der dritten Liga spielen lassen oder was? Ja, und bei Gladbach haben sie sogar aussortiert. Und jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich, wenn er im Sommer verkauft wird, den ganzen Club für drei Jahre finanzieren. Ja, ein Typ. Und das ist natürlich auch die Irrsinnheit des Fußballs. Das ist eben so, ja, der ganze Fußball ist ein bisschen aus solchen Wetten aufgebaut. Und macht es halt auch so spannend. Weil du hast diese Ausschläge, die du immer mal kriegen kannst, die du bei Bayer oder bei VW in der Form eben nicht hast, wenn du da Aktien hältst.
Ja, ich glaube, das unterscheidet den Fußball auch noch von anderen Sportarten. Zum Beispiel wird ja immer wieder auch in dieser Szene von Moneyball gesprochen, dieser Film über Baseball und dass man alles Datenbasiert, quasi die Spieler verpflichten könnte. Das ist ja der heilige Gral quasi so für Private Equity Investoren, wenn es um Investitionen in den Sport geht. Und das ist beim Fußball einfach komplett anders. Das funktioniert ja nicht. Wie Christoph Krupp als Zeitallmahler gesagt hat, wenn man jetzt, keine Ahnung, Marius Bülter auch noch bei euch da irgendwie noch mit rein nimmt, der hat ja eine ganz gegenteilige Karriere gemacht.
Outs bitte nicht.
Einfach nur Outs.
Couché.
Kommt aus meiner eigenen Stadt, deswegen habe ich hier angeführt. Kommt auch aus Rheine. Naja, auf jeden Fall die... Ich glaube halt, dass man... Also zum Beispiel bei Frankfurt hat man ja am Anfang der Saison auch gesagt, boah, haben die gut eingekauft, das wird ja eine Champions League, also garantiert Champions League. Ja, was ist passiert? Jetzt stehen sie da irgendwo im Mittelfeld. Also das zeigt einfach nur immer wieder, dass Fußball so anders ist als auch alle US-Sportarten beispielsweise, wo man mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit voraussagen kann, dass Spieler x, y einen Korb aus x oder y Metern da irgendwie immer trifft. So deswegen glaube ich einfach, ja, das wurde von vielen einfach auch US-Investoren ein bisschen, ja, da wurde das Risiko falsch eingeschätzt in der Vergangenheit.
Ja und gleichzeitig ist es aber so, viele dieser Erfolgsgeschichten, die schreibt der Fußball ja so oder so. Also für Saad El Mala hat es ja kein Investor gebraucht, der reingekommen ist und mit seinem klugen Datennetzwerk gesagt hat, hier behalte den, sondern da hatte der FC einfach Glück. Und der Unterschied zwischen einem guten und einem schlechten Sportdirektor, der liegt im Prozentbereich. Also ein sehr guter Sportdirektor, der trifft 60 Prozent seiner Transfers. Das werden dann Spieler, die eben nennenswerte Minuten spielen. Und einer, den man eher als schlecht bewertet, der trifft 40 Prozent seiner Transfers. Das ist so ungefähr die Range, von der man da im Business zumindest spricht. Das heißt, alles, was man hier quasi suggeriert, also durch Investoren, also klar, du hast dein Geld und kannst einkaufen und kannst aber genauso schlecht oder gut einkaufen wie vorher. Und es hängt auch an ganz vielen Dingen ab, die du nicht kontrollieren kannst, weil Fußball eben einfach so, das macht ja den Fußball so toll, ehrlicherweise. Dafür brauchst du keine Investoren. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch überhaupt nicht planbar, was ja eigentlich, also du hast es jetzt schön rausgestellt, Christoph, warum denn Investoren reingehen, weil eigentlich denken Investoren immer in Risiken und immer in Risikomanagement. Okay, und hier lerne ich jetzt, die Emotionalität führt sie im Fußball dazu, trotzdem reinzugehen. Gleichzeitig ist aber halt auch eine Aufforderung an alle Fans da draußen. Wenn ihr keine Investoren wollt, dann sagt das bitte bei jedem Spiel, weil wenn Dietmar Hopp keine Lust mehr hat, also wenn es für den nicht mehr angenehm ist, an jedem Moment auf der Tribüne zu sitzen in Hoffenheim, weil die Fans protestieren, dann ist diese emotionale Redite vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so groß. Und wir haben es ja auch ein bisschen gemerkt. Also als es diese Banner gab, ich glaube bei Union Berlin damals, Angst Potter, was sich auf Graeme Potter bezogen hat, der eben hinter einem dieser großen Private Equity Firmen stand, die eben einsteigen wollten bei der DFL. Da hat das nach allem, was wir drei so gehört haben, sage ich mal, hat das durchaus von der Reaktion gesorgt. Also dass eben tatsächlich die Investoren dann auch gesagt haben, boah, lohnt sich das hier in die Bundesliga reinzugehen, wenn die Fans ihre Tennisbälle werfen, wenn das so unberechenbar ist und wenn halt einfach die Stimmung so grundsätzlich schlecht ist gegenüber Investoren. Weil, ehrlicherweise, die Investoren haben auch die Bundesliga nicht gebraucht. Die hatten genug andere Ligen und Sportarten, in die sie reingehen konnten. Was aber für mich dann so ein bisschen die Frage aufwirft, ja, wie wird das denn jetzt weitergehen? Also ich möchte mal noch eine Geschichte dazu oder etwas, was jetzt eben gerade sich am Markt entwickelt, mit reinwerfen. Und dann könnt ihr ja gerne mal so eure Einschätzung abgeben, ob das was aussagt. Also wir kennen den Public Investment Fonds von Saudi Arabien. Irre, irre groß. Also schier unermessliches Geld. Und damit haben sie ja auch sich ganz, ganz viel gekauft. Unter anderem mindestens 300 Beteiligungen und Sponsorships im weltweiten Sport. Aber dieser ach so große und endlose Topf, der war auf einmal endlich. Im November 25 soll laut New York Times, dem Public Investment Fund, das Geld ausgegangen sein. Und das liegt auch daran, dass viele der Assets in finanziellen Schwierigkeiten stecken und deswegen schwer abzustoßen sind. Zum Beispiel das ganze Neum-Projekt. Also wenn ihr mal wissen wollt, googelt einfach The Line. Offenbar machen sie jetzt die Line doch nicht. Was das für das WM-Stadion, das es ursprünglich mal in 60 Metern Höhe geben sollte, bedeutet, weiß man nicht, aber das war eh alles immer nur Quatsch. Alles nur Marketing. Aber deswegen hat PEF sämtliche weitere Investitionen gestoppt. Der Kauf von Electronic Arts für 55 Milliarden US-Dollar soll vorerst die letzte Investition im Sportbereich bleiben. Da würde ich als Laie, Jannik, jetzt sagen, ist das ein Zeichen dafür, dass sich die Kaufwut der Investoren langsam abkühlt, der ganze Markt sich beruhigt und dann aber auch manche der Investoren auf ein Problem zu laufen, weil dann eben nicht mehr die Bewertungen steigen und man eben eine Exit-Strategie hat, wenn man wieder Geld braucht?
Ja, also ich sehe das auf jeden Fall so. Bei Saudi-Arabien oder generell bei den Investoren aus dem Mittleren Osten muss man jetzt, glaube ich, sowieso so ein bisschen abwarten, wie sich die Lage da entwickelt. Genau, das war ja quasi der große Topf der letzten Jahre. Aber es war auch schon so langsam, man hat es gesehen, wie du auch gesagt hast, Neon habe ich mir gerade so im Hintergrund aufgeschrieben. Es ist schon seit mehreren zwei, drei Jahren jetzt mit dabei, dass der Ölpreis ja ziemlich unter Druck geraten ist. Also das vergisst man jetzt gerade, wenn man mal an die Tankstätte schaut. Aber es war ja so, dass der Ölpreis auf einem Niveau lag, der einfach gar nicht mehr wirtschaftlich war für diese Region. Jetzt werden natürlich, jetzt sind die Ölpreise zwar hoch, aber Energieanlagen werden gedroht, dass sie angegriffen werden. Und der Tourismus leidet vor allen Dingen. Also das heißt, man muss da so ein bisschen gerade schauen in dieser Region, wo es wirklich hingeht in Zukunft. Und ich glaube, da wird Sport noch mal sehr kritisch beleuchtet werden, ob das wirklich so das große, der große Investment-Case war, oder ob man sich da so ein bisschen auch die Illusion gemacht hat und einfach vielleicht auch mit Spaß investiert hat, was wir gerade auch schon ein paar Mal hatten. Ich erinnere mich auch, ich habe einen Kumpel, der bei meiner großen Unternehmensberatung war und der hat mir berichtet, dass die beim, dass der, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der PIF war, ich glaube, es war der PIF. Die haben so absurde Projekte bei denen in Auftrag gegeben. Da sollte mal geprüft werden, ob man dort wohl auf dem Busch Al-Arab, glaube ich, Bienenstöcke anbringen könnte, ob man dann nicht Bienen in Saudi-Arabien ja irgendwie züchten könnte. Turns out, konnte man nicht, hat dem Prinzen aber nicht gefallen. Und dann hat der gesagt, dann prüft halt, wie es geht. Und dann wurde halt eine zweite Studie für ein paar Hunderttausend Euro in Aufsage gegeben und dann kam raus, es geht halt doch. Und so ist dann halt das. Ja, das sind solche absurden Geschichten, die dann irgendwie aus dieser Region kommen, wo einfach gesagt wird, das Geld ist egal, macht mal irgendwas. Hauptsache, da kommt eben das richtige Ergebnis raus. Und ich glaube, das wird jetzt ein bisschen abnehmen. Also ich sage irgendwie so ein bisschen verquatsch beim Thema in der Ostern- oder Saudi-Arabien. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich glaube, dass wird tatsächlich so ein bisschen aus dieser Region wird der Geldhahn so ein bisschen zugedreht werden.
Und was bedeutet das dann oder könnte das bedeuten, Christoph? Für wenn, wenn dieser eine Hahn zugeht, geht ein anderer auf?
Ich sehe es gar nicht so so negativ. Ich sehe es eigentlich so, dass natürlich in jedem Markt, der mal so einen Hype erlebt, hast du immer diese Boom-and-Buzz-Phase. Also dann wird es hochgelobt und dann geht es wieder runter. Das geht ja für viele andere Märkte auch. Tech und was auch immer. Bitcoin hast du selber angesprochen. Da geht es in sehr viel kürzeren Zyklen. Ja, alle paar Monate eine andere Story. Aber das heißt, das ist immer auch eine. Gesundung irgendwo. So das Beispiel, das du jetzt gebracht hast mit Saudi Arabien, also diese Staatsfonds, die die zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt viel zu viel Geld hatten und das auch im Prinzip gar nicht vernünftig gemanagt haben, mussten sie lange auch nicht, weil es egal war, weil die einfach mit der Schrotflinte geballert haben im übertragenen Sinne und ein paar Treffer hatten. Es hat gereicht. Das ist halt nicht mehr der Fall. Die würde ich aber nicht als typisch sehen. Die waren schon wichtig für den Markt, aber so eine gewisse Beruhigung könnte auch den Vorteil haben, dass ich bin ja nach wie vor dafür, das will ich noch mal unterstreichen, ich glaube, dass Investoren im Fußball schon helfen können in bestimmten Bereichen. Aber das führt dazu oder könnte dazu führen, dass diejenigen Investoren, die den Sport, den Fußball einigermaßen verstehen und das Stück weit auch besser respektieren als vielleicht andere mit seinen Eigenheiten und trotzdem ein Know-how reinbringen können, was der Branche hilft, zu professionalisieren. Weil die Tatsache, dass die Gehälter so gestrichen für die Führungskräfte, ist ja auch ein Zeichen, dass der Fußball Leute anziehen möchte, die das besser managen können. Und da ist noch viel Luft nach oben auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, die, die es verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit sind diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit sind diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen. Also das ist ja das, was die Engländer gemacht haben. Die haben am Anfang auch irgendwelche halbseitigen griechischen Räder gehabt, die Clubs gekauft haben, als sie angefangen haben, die die Anzahl zu verkaufen und haben gemerkt, oh, nicht so eine gute Idee. Und dann haben die Regeln aufgestellt, welche Investoren sie überhaupt haben wollen. Da kann man nicht lang drüber streiten. Die liegen ja bei der DFL auch schon lange in der Schublade, dass man die irgendwann mal rausziehen kann, wenn man die braucht, wenn man eine Mehrheit hat, eine strukturelle. Aber das heißt, diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit die Branche respektieren mit ihren Besonderheiten und trotzdem einen Mehrwert dergestalten mit sich bringen, dass sie Führungskraft, Management-Fähigkeiten mitbringen und dem Fußball dann ein Stück weit helfen, die könnten davon profitieren, weil die werden nicht mehr verdrängt, oder weniger verdrängt von den Irren mit den Geldkoffern. Das könnte eine Folge sein und dann wäre es eine gute Folge. Du fragst aber zurecht, was heißt das für die, die jetzt geguckt haben, ich will eigentlich in fünf Jahren wieder raus. Die müsste ich möglicherweise anpassen. Ob das dann in jeder Hinsicht für die Club so ein Desaster ist, vermag ich gar nicht zu sagen, weil Stück weit sind das ja nur Anteile und Bewertungen. Also wenn die Anteile des Investors am Club an Wert verlieren vor dem Gesamtmarkt, hat das für den Club erstmal keine riesen Folgen, weil der Club macht ja weiter und die Finanzen des Clubs sind ja schon da. Der Bewert ist geringer. Es kann sein, dass der Investor dann vielleicht nicht mehr so Bock hat, sich zu engagieren, blabla, was auch immer, aber zunächst mal ändert es für die Clubs gar nichts.
Vielleicht können dann Genossenschaften sogar die eigenen Anteile zurückkaufen. Das ist ein sehr, sehr großer Schritt.
Genau, das wäre auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, wobei man dann, also ich muss sagen, ich habe so ein kleines Störgefühl, wenn immer davon ausgegangen wird, dass teuer bezahlte Manager auch bessere Manager sind. Das ist für mich auch so eine Mehrheit. Aber komplett falsch ist es natürlich auch nicht, weil ich auch weiß, wie in manchen Bundesligaklubs gearbeitet wird. Oder zumindest glaube zu wissen. Und da gäbe es dann schon noch Optimierungspotenzial.
Nein, teurer heißt nicht besser. Das ist schon klar, das ist nicht grundsätzlich besser. Aber es zeigt schon, dass der Fußball sich da große Mühe gibt oder da Leute anzieht und anziehen möchte, die auch aus anderen Branchen Know-how mitbringen, die den Fußball gebrauchen kann. Und da gibt es schon sicherlich noch bessere Besserungspotenzial in vielen Bereichen.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Und gleichzeitig muss aber halt, wenn man beim deutschen Markt bleibt, bei den Bundesligisten und Zweitbundesligisten, muss man halt auch die Frage stellen, warum braucht ihr eigentlich Geld? Also das ist ja, glaube ich, auch das, wo externe Manager besser werden. Also der Fußball hat ein Ausgabenproblem. Sie nehmen wahnsinnig viel ein und sie geben ein bisschen mehr aus, als sie einnehmen. Und deswegen segeln sie eben immer so hart an der Kante. Aber eigentlich ist das Geld da, wenn du in die Bilanzen reinguckst, ist immer alles gebunden in Spielergehälter, in Handgelder, in Infrastruktur und so weiter. Also es sieht komplett anders aus, wenn du in einem Verein arbeitest, da hast du das Gefühl, du hast gar keinen Spielraum. Da brauchst du wirklich jetzt den Sponsor, der drei Millionen nochmal gibt, weil dann hast du endlich wieder drei Millionen, die du für irgendwas einsetzen kannst. Aber de facto ist es eigentlich nicht so, wenn man die strategische Position einnimmt, das machen halt die meisten nicht, weil sie nur von Saison zu Saison denken. Von der strategischen Position her ist eigentlich gar nicht so viel Geld gebunden. Du kannst eigentlich noch ganz gut organisieren, weil du hast so einen Fixed Income über Merchandise, über TV-Einnahmen und so weiter und so fort. Der hat eine Variabilität, aber die kannst du ja einpreisen. Wird ja alles gemacht, das ist ja alles kein Hexenwerk. Und du hast Fixkosten, aber an die kann man eigentlich ganz gut ansetzen. Du musst dann nur manche unangenehme Entscheidungen treffen und die wird sich dann eben auf dem Spielfeld zeigen, weil da sind die Fixkosten am höchsten. Und das wollen sie dann immer alle nicht.
Das können wir noch für alle abstellen.
Genau. Aber dafür ist ja dann vielleicht gut, wenn die Manager irgendwann so viel verdienen, dann kann man dann sagen, ja gut, dann entlassen wir jetzt einen Manager. Also die Vorstände, die entlassen wurden beim FC Bayern, also Oliver Kahn, Hasan Salihamidzic und noch ein Dritter war mit dabei, ich glaube Jörg Wacker, haben 16,8 Millionen Euro Abfindung erhalten, laut Handelsregisterauszug, konnte man sich damals runterlegen. Ja, war dann auch einmal teuer. Aber vielleicht könnte man sich auch solche Kosten mal sparen. Gut, aber da will ich jetzt mit euch beiden als Köln und HSV-Fan nicht drüber reden. Das sind nur zu große Wunden, in die wir da nochmal bohren. Habt ihr noch letzte Gedanken? Jannik, hast du noch was, was dir zu dem Thema noch auf der Seele brennt?
Ich bin schon vieles losgeworden. Ich glaube auch, dass, was du sagst, dass Vereine mittelfristig erst mal noch durchlauferhitzer bleiben werden und dass es nicht weniger Kapitalbedarf gibt. Grundsätzlich, also es wird irgendwie weitergehen. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass es auf einem gesünderen Niveau weitergeht. Also eine kontrolliertere Kompetenzialisierung nenne ich es jetzt einfach mal. Also tendenziell irgendwie noch mal mehr Synergien versucht werden zu schaffen. Aber halt auf einer vernünftigen, auf einer vernünftigeren Basis, dass man ja vielleicht versucht, mehr über Schulden zu machen. Weniger über Paradequity, weil das so ein bisschen auch die Freiheit den Verein überlässt und diese Diskussion, diese elendigen Diskussionen, um Investoren im Profifußball so ein bisschen kleiner hält. Dafür müsste man dann halt auch wirklich, was du sagst, Max, man müsste an die Kosten ran. Und ich glaube, das würde dem Sport im Gesamten ganz guttun, auch wenn ich Christophs Position dann auch verstehe, dass man zu Investoren ein gewisses Know-how mitbringen und was dem Sport auch guttun würde. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, das wird schwierig werden, aber meine Hoffnung ist, dass es gesünder weitergeht einfach.
Du hast halt im Sport jetzt noch eine Besonderheit, da müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail reingehen, aber du hast halt einfach dieses weirde Eigenkapital im Fußball. Und dadurch, dass jetzt ja man sich gewisse Grenzen setzt und du ja beim Fremdkapital aufnehmen, dann das Eigenkapital logischerweise eine große Rolle spielt, aber das Eigenkapital eben einfach so seltsam ist im Fußball, weil wenn du einen Spieler kaufst, du dann immateriales Eigenkapital liegen hast, dann sah er, der Maler, der liegt aber noch gar nicht in der Bilanz, weil der kommt aus der eigenen Jugend, verkürzt gesprochen, bilanciell gesprochen. Das heißt, der ist gerade kein Wert, de facto ist er es aber doch. Und das ist natürlich, da verstehe ich auch die Vereine, dass das nicht immer so einfach ist, wie es von Seiten Fans aus aussieht. Also die kriegen halt auch nicht die besten Zinsen, um es jetzt mal sozusagen. Übrigens auch der 1. FC Köln nicht. Da habe ich auch die Bodensee Bank war das doch damals, glaube ich. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal ganz anders.
Die Bodensee Bank hat eine ganz große Rolle im Fußball. Ja, ja, ganz, ganz wichtiger Player. Vielleicht darf ich noch eine Sache am Schluss sagen, Max. Also was ich mir wünschen würde für Deutschland, also ich bin jetzt, ich würde mir wünschen, dass die, dass die, die Liga aus dieser ganzen Investoren Diskussion, die um sie herumtobt, ein Stück weit, die wir auch natürlich hier auch hatten, den Schluss zieht, dass man vielleicht 50 plus 1 hin oder her sich mal überlegen muss, auf Sicht, welche Investoren kann ich mir überhaupt vorstellen, weil die Tatsache, was bei Hertha passiert ist, haben wir ja eingangs drüber gesprochen, mit erst KKR, dann Wintors, dann 777. Zumindest die letzten beiden hätten natürlich nie Investoren werden dürfen. Und zwar nicht aus Sicht von Hertha, die haben erst mal für sich entschieden, was für sie das Beste ist. Verstehe ich. Ja, so viel Kohle und der hatte keine Ahnung, alles gut. Aber die Liga als Ganze ist massiv beschädigt worden, da du ja die ganze Denke über Investoren. Und wenn ich als Liga sage, ich möchte mir diese Option offenhalten, irgendwann vielleicht in irgendeiner Form den deutschen Fußball stärker zu öffnen. Das geht ja möglicherweise auch mit 50 plus 1. Das ist ja nicht. Dann muss ich mir aber Gedanken machen, wie managere ich das als Liga? Welche Regeln stelle ich auf? Welche Investoren möchte ich dann? Wie suche ich die aus? Wie bewerte ich die? Und das würde ich mir wünschen, dass das mal passiert, weil das gibt auch eine ewige Debatte. Da kannst du ewig darüber diskutieren, welche Art von Investoren du zulassen willst. Welche Regeln setzt du denen? Da geht es ja auch um Haltefristen zum Beispiel. Wie lange müssen die engagiert bleiben? Wenn du die Haltefristen lang machst, kannst du Private-Equities schon mal mehr oder weniger ausschließen, weil die gehen dann gar nicht rein, weil denen das zu lange ist. Da kannst du ganz viel gestalten als Liga, wenn du es willst. Und du kannst, wie soll ich sagen, natürlich auch versuchen, in Deutschland sehr schwierig, aber versuchen, gewisserweise Vertrauen zu entwickeln für diese Idee, dass man in irgendeiner Form dritten Zugang ermöglicht in den Fußball. Und das sehe ich eigentlich kaum. Wir haben ja auch diese anderen Player in Augsburg und so weiter. Das ist alles wild west eigentlich. Und das schadet eigentlich dem Fußball, dem deutschen Fußball, viel stärker, weil es durch die Position derjenigen, die komplett dagegen sind, ständig stärkt, tagtäglich. Was hat der Windhorst, die haben doch gejubelt, als er eingestiegen ist, die ganzen komplett Hardcore-Gegner von InterStorm, weil die gesagt haben, na wunderbar, der beweist alle Klischees, die wir immer hatten. Oder alle, das sind ja eigentlich überall Klischees. Und das hat die Liga bisher, meinst du, nicht gemacht. Und das ist ein Riesenversäumnis eigentlich. Die machen das jetzt im Kleinen, indem sie Projekte aufsetzen, internationale Vermarktung jetzt machen, eigene Plattformen ausessen, laufen ja gerade riesen Dinge. Aber das wird so ein bisschen unter der Hand immer gemacht. Und da mal eine Debatte zu führen, um zu sagen, naja, wenn es denn so kommt, wie machen wir das denn dann? Auch vor dem Hintergrund der Wolfsburg-Leverkusen-Kartellamts-Diskussion.
Das ist es.
Das fände ich extrem spannend und möglicherweise auch, auch wenn das auch hart werden würde, aber einen großen Gewinn für die Liga, wenn man da weiterkommen würde, etwas. Und das sehe ich nicht. Und deswegen werden wir auch da drin sitzen bleiben, die wir haben. Dann ist uns auch egal, wie viel im sonstigen Fußball tobt an Investorenirrsinn. Und das da nur immer indirekt betrifft, weil die uns alle Spieler wegkaufen, die attraktiv sind, wie die Liga als Ganze braucht, nicht der Club einzeln. Wenn so ein Al Malhar weggeht jetzt nach England, der jetzt kein fertiger Superstar ist natürlich, wird er wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden. Ich weiß es nicht, aber dafür ist er glaube ich zu beschränkt, aber sportlich glaube ich. Aber wenn der jetzt auch weggeht, ist natürlich ein Phänomen der Typ. Und natürlich cool, wenn er noch zwei Jahre bleiben würde, weil er halt echt coole Sachen macht und die Leute mitnimmt und spektakuläre Tore schießt. Wenn der jetzt nach Brighton oder wo auch immer dahin gehen wird, ist er auch wieder weg. Eigentlich auch schade für die Liga, auch wenn der uns nicht zur WM schießen wird, irgendwann.
Ja, wobei, also ich finde die Frage hochspannend. Ich stelle mir aber auch die Frage, warum eigentlich nie darüber diskutiert wird, wenn Investoren so toll sind, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Warum haben denn dann nicht alle Vereine außer die Werksclubs 49% ihre Anteile verkauft? Weil das wäre ja möglich. Und es muss ja auch, es gibt ja auch Investoren, die zu weniger als 51% reingehen. Das sehen wir ja gerade im US-Sport. Da sehen wir allerdings auch, dass die Gruppe Arktos 38 Investments hat, in allen US-Sport-Ligen, mit 7,2 Milliarden US-Dollar. Also die sind einfach überall reingegangen. Aber ich finde, das ist eigentlich auch eine interessante Frage, die viel zu selten gestellt wird.
Klar, absolut.
Ja, ich glaube, auf jeden Fall ist eine wichtige Frage. Ich glaube einfach, dass in den Club-Strukturen, man muss sich immer bewusst sein, was passiert, wenn solche Investoren reingeholt werden. Und was wollen solche Investoren, die Anteile halten? Die wollen Macht. Und niemand will sich aber bei diesem Verein da reinquatschen lassen, weil es nun mal auch interessengetriebene Vereine sind. Ich glaube, dieses Abgeben von Macht, das hindert viele daran, dass man da noch stärker Investoren bis zu 49 Prozent reinholt.
Ja, beziehungsweise, also das stimmt und das ist auch ein sehr emotionales Thema. Sehr gutes Beispiel, das sogenannte Weltmarkenbündnis beim VfB Stuttgart und die Aufsichtsratsdiskussion. Der e.V. muss der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende sein, ist auch richtig so, ist auch meine Interpretation von 50 plus 1. Aber eigentlich haben wir da ja schon genau solche Strukturen. Bei Werder Bremen auch, bei Eintracht Frankfurt auch. Die sitzen halt nur in den Gremien, die wir nie sehen. Also niemand kann auswendig alle Aufsichtsratsmitglieder seines Vereins her sagen. Egal wie groß er als Fan ist. Außer er hat dafür einen besonderen Fetisch, sage ich jetzt mal. Und da sitzen ja diese Investoren schon drin. Und es gibt ja Investoren, die sagen, ey, das reicht mir auch. Ich will ja gar nicht im Daily Business mit dabei sein. Aber ich will schon mitsprechen, wenn wir große Entscheidungen treffen, wenn wir strategische Entscheidungen treffen und wenn wir den Vorstand berufen. Weil da will ich jemand haben, der Kompetenz hat in dem Bereich. Und da gibt es ja eigentlich schon sehr viele Wege für Investoren in den deutschen Sport, in den Fußball, auch in die Bundesliga. Interessant, dass es dann doch eigentlich gar nicht so viele gehen. Und die Bewertung von Werder Bremen, das wäre noch mal ein eigenes Thema. Da ist jetzt gerade wieder jemand reingegangen. Es ist ja schockierend, für wie wenig Geld man bei Werder Bremen einsteigen kann. Wenn ich ein bisschen Geld hätte, liebe Hörer und Hörer, spendet. Nee, macht es nicht. Also macht es nicht deshalb. Macht es aber. Ich werde nicht bei Werder reingehen. Also, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat, wie beim letzten Mal auch schon, sehr große Freude gemacht. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, vielleicht wird das so eine Runde so einmal im Jahr. Geben wir mal wieder so ein Update. Herzlichen Dank an Jannik Tillar von Kapital und Stern. Vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke, Max. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und herzlichen Dank an Christoph Neßhöver, wie immer. Ich freue mich auch immer richtig, euch zu sehen. Das hat echt Spaß gemacht. Danke dir, lieber Christoph vom Manager-Magazin natürlich. Danke dir.
Sehr, sehr gern. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier machen, ist nicht von irgendeinem Investor finanziert, sondern von ganz vielen Investorinnen und Investoren da draußen, nämlich von euch. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei, weil ich vermute, dass diese Sendung auch Fachfremde, Hörerinnen und Hörer hören, möchte ich nochmal betonen. Keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren, keine Paywall, denn alle drei Dinge sind nicht mit den Werten des Rasenfunks vereinbar. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung da draußen. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de, wenn ihr auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt oder einfach in der Podcast und Video Beschreibung ganz leicht zu finden. Und es geht auch innerhalb von Sekunden. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. In der Folge möchte ich mich da bedanken bei Patrick E., bei Lenz, zweimal bei Jan, bei Julia und bei Dagobard. Das passt natürlich sehr gut zu dieser Sendung. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de Und ansonsten sage ich jetzt an der Stelle auch mal, man kann uns auch auf LinkedIn folgen. Ich glaube, das ist hier die richtige Sendung, um das mal anzusprechen. In diesem Sinne abonniert den Rasenfunk, empfiehlt uns weiter, unterstützt uns sehr gerne finanziell und werdet oder bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald wieder. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.